Miami Beach Police Officer is asking for
whistleblower protection after releasing
video of a fellow officer punching an
unarmed man and the violent incident
happened December 3rd at a restaurant an
officer can be seen striking a man hard
enough to knock him on the ground
Jericka Duncan shows us what's behind
the video's release triggered good
morning good morning well we spoke to
the attorney for the whistleblower
Fredrik Dominguez and he has no relation
to Audrey o Dominguez the officer who
threw the punch now according to the
attorney the police report of the
incident does not match what actually
happened and his client is hoping to be
protected from retaliation for what he
calls an act of bravery officers
responded to this South Beach hotel
following reports a man was acting irate
screaming loudly and cursing at others
police say a confrontation soon began
between Batman while Poitier and officer
Audrey Dominguez with one swing the
officer not poitiers out cold according
to the police report Poitier clenched
his fists and took a fighting stance
causing the officer to fear for his
safety qua ta was arrested and charged
with assault resisting an officer and
disorderly conduct for actions allegedly
not seen on video he thought it was
outrageous he thought it was really
sickening Michael Pizzi is the attorney
for Frederick Dominguez an officer who
was not at the scene that night dizzy
says his client heard about the incident
from fellow officers and decided to find
the video from the department's body cam
footage after a week went by and nobody
did anything to expose it nobody
investigated it and the report was
fabricated officer Dominguez felt that
he had an obligation to come forward and
achieve justice the Miami Beach Police
Union strongly defended the officer in
the video writing there is no question
officer odd Rael Dominguez was legally
justified and fully entitled to protect
himself but Pizzey disagrees and says
his client now fears retaliation I hope
the police chief and Miami Beach sends a
message that they are going to encourage
people to come forward and report
misconduct
and they're going to protect people who
show integrity and who show bravery and
do the right thing an internal affairs
investigation has been launched into the
conduct of officer a drill Dominguez who
worked at the Department for just two
years he has been taken off of patrol
duty the whistleblower whistleblowers
attorney told us he has not yet heard
back from the police chief and hopes to
get a response about protection soon but
his client does plan to show up to work
today well very brave of the police
officer to turn against a fellow police
officer but when you see it on videotape
it is disturbing I do think the suspect
was close that what what absolute
challenging words in in many
neighborhoods but you still you expect
the police officer to handle it
differently right
thank you drink up thank you Jericho